do you know friends that Chad GPD is an
open AI Cutting Edge tool which was
launched in
2022 and it just gained 1 million users
in 1 month compared to Netflix 3 and 1/2
years and Instagram 2 and 1/2 months now
if you want to learn more about how Chad
GPT can be used to learn reactjs then
watch this video till the end but before
that I request you guys that do not
forget to hit the Subscribe button and
click the Bell icon so let's start the
session if you are looking to get
certified as an AI or ml engineer then
hey there you are at the right place so
let us take a tour to know what simply
learns postgraduate program in
generative Ai and machine learning has
for you you're are going to earn a
certificate of completion from I of
Divas Park IIT Ri so you are going to go
by I RI curriculum and the session will
be online and it will be taken by
industry experts you going to get master
class delivered by faculties from
Premier Institute like iits and nits
you're going to gain exposure to the
latest AI advancements such as
generative AI prompt engineering and
chat gbt you're going to have a
dedicated live project training for
crucial topics in generative AI you are
also going to get opportunity to attend
a two-day campus immersion program by IH
have Divya park at IAT RI certificates
will be available for IBM courses and
Industry master classes by IBM expert
you're going to get exclusive hackathon
and ask me anything sessions by IBM
simply learns job assistance is also
going to help you to get notice by top
hiring companies you'll work on 25 plus
Hands-On industry relevant projects and
three industry oriented Capstone
projects and you're going to build your
expertise in 20 plus tools and
techniques with seamless access to
integrated Labs hurry up and enroll Now
find the course Link in the description
box so guys let's start with what is
chat GPD chat GPD is an Advanced AI
powered natural language processing tool
designed for engaging in humanlike
conversation and also performing variety
of task it can provide answers to
questions and with help activities like
crafting emails and even generating code
in different programming language so
guys let us navigate to chat
GPD so first go to
open.com now here is your open Ai and in
this we'll get chat GPD so as you can
see all over here we have a login button
just right click on this as you can see
all over here in order to login from
this you can continue with Google
Microsoft account or an Apple account so
I would prefer going with Google account
so just right click on this and my chat
GPD is going to get just opened now you
can also use chat GPD to generate dummy
data or write unit test and translate
text or code from one language to other
let me show you here so suppose I write
all over here
write a python
code for
Fibonacci
series so as you can see I have written
the prompt all over here now we are
going to get a result for the Fibonacci
series so I'm just going to say copy the
same code and say translate this
code in
Java
so as you can see the a code is going to
get translated in Java so this is the
beauty of chat GPD let me also show you
something else for development purposes
guys you can also use chat GPD to create
dummy data so suppose I write a prompt
something like this H CH
GPT can you provide
me a dummy data
for my
hotels
website
okay so as you can see all over here I'm
going to get a particular dummy data for
our hotels so as you can see all over
here the given code generated is the
dummy data now as you can see what are
the parameters so it's hotels there is a
ID there's a name disc ion location
rating image room okay now this is a
special quality of char gbt It's very
effective now suppose I have to write a
unit test so let me show you also that
so if I say h CH
gbt can you
write unit
test check
if login
button for my react
component so now I know it's going to
give a generic code but that's also very
useful so as you can see all over here
so it has given a demo suppose all over
here there's a login button okay now for
that login button in which where you are
clicking it and after clicking it
becomes a login okay this basically a
login button so in order to check this
functionality how we can write it we can
write unit test with a library called
just which is a react testing Library so
all over here we can say we have render
and fire event from the library testing
then we are importing the login button
and inside it we are rendering the login
button and as an Arrow function has been
passed all over here inside this you can
see mock on click or cons get by ID
suppose you not able to understand
certain part of the code chat GPT is
even helpful in that scenario so suppose
if I say what is this okay can you
explain me this line of code okay so let
us ask chat
GPD please explain this
code
line by
line even in that scenario in order to
understand how it's working chat GPT is
going to explain you line by line I hope
so guys you would have got a brief idea
regarding Chad GPT now let's move on and
understand about how chat GPT is helpful
with react now guys I know that chat GPT
can be very helpful resource while
learning react GS let me show you how so
as you can see when react combines with
chat GPT your development becomes very
very smoother so there are certain
functionalities what are the first one
you get a chance for interactive
question and answers you can engage in
Q&A session with chat gbt to clarify any
doubts you may have for instance you can
ask about react components State props
or the virtual drum and any question if
you are feeling any doubt or difficulty
next thing is you get code EX examp you
can request code Snippets for simple
react.js applications you can ask for
examples for creating components
handling States and using props you can
discuss the code with chat GPT to
understand the logic behind it next you
get the debugging tips if we talk about
debugging tips if you encounter any
issues or error while coding you can
describe the problem to chat GPT and ask
the debugging tips this interactive
debugging approach can provide insights
into problem solving next come is your
documentation chat GPT is very very
helpful in documentation you can use
chat GPT to guide you through react.js
documentation ask for explanation on
specific Concepts methods or features
that you find challenging now let's move
on and understand some Hands-On thing
how we can Implement chat GPT in our
reactjs development now guys let's move
on and understand how we can use chat
GPT to learn
reactjs so you can ask certain prompts
something like this the first one let us
try to get an outline for the react JS
tutorial so for the same you can go on
the chat GPT and
type give me the
outline for the react J
tutorial
now we will wait for chat GPT to answer
that
prompt so guys as you can see all over
here chat GPT has given a proper road
map for our learning so the starting
from introduction to reactjs then what
is reactjs why to use reactjs reactjs
features and advantages then is setting
up a development environments then comes
react components then jsx handling EV
reacts State Management react life cycle
methods conditional rendering list and
keys forms in react react router State
Management so you can see there are a
couple of things more now let us go to
our second prompt and let us see how we
can set up our development environment
now our second prompt will be how we are
going to set up our development
environment so let us write the
prompt H
GPT
so guys I have said that hey GPT can you
guide me how to set up development
environment in vs code so as you can see
the steps have come up first of all
install the visual studio code so just
right click on the next one okay and
here install vs
code so we typed of the first thing so
as you can see we can download our text
editor from here now what's the next
step install npm and node okay so for
installing the node what you can do so
here is given the official website just
right click on this one so you can
download your your nodejs from here now
the third step comes up creating a react
app so let me show you guys so as you
can see I have downloaded my text editor
and also I have downloaded nodejs now
let us go at file and create a new file
and let us name it as
index.js now go to the terminal and type
new terminal and here now we are going
to copy this thing so let us copy and
let us go to our vs code okay and
here just paste that command so as you
can see guys our react application is
starting to set
up now what's the next command now the
next step is CD my react app so let us
go to our vs code and type the same so
let us go to our designated folder by
typing
CD my
app okay there are some errors coming up
let us see what are the errors okay so
as you can see let's see the folder
structure
first
okay okay now we have easily navigated
to my reactor okay now let us type the
final thing that is running the react
application that is npm start so all
over here go to the terminal and type
the
same so this is going to start our react
application so as you can see guys with
the help of chat GPD we have easily run
our react application and let me show
you the demo part since our server is
running up and here our react
application will get loaded so
congratulation guys we have done it the
first step is setting up our development
environment let us see now what holds to
next the third thing is we have to ask
chat GPD what are components in react so
let us see whether chat GPT can answer
our queries or not so we have gone to
our chat GPT and let us
ask
water
components react so as you can see guys
chat GPT has answered our query it says
that in react a component is
self-contained reusable piece of code
that represents a part of user interface
components are like building blocks of a
react application and they can be
thought of a custom reusable HTML
elements react applications are
typically structured as tree of
components so it says that what
component is it's a part of the user
interface that is kind of reusable piece
of code so here there are two types of
components the first one is functional
component so what are functional
components so they are also known as the
stateless components which are defined
as JavaScript functions they receive
props which are also known as properties
as arguments and they return the react
elements it is also used for simple UI
components that don't need to man state
or life cycle method for example
function welcome the props has passed
and we are returning an H1 tag with
hello and for the name we are typing
props do name got it something like this
is called functional component now if
you see the class components so in
JavaScript if you have studied about
classes it's something similar to that
they are also known as stateful
component defined in es6 classes and it
extends from react do component they can
have state and life cycle methods and
they are basically used for more complex
UI components that need to manage
internal state or respond to life cycle
events so suppose I'm not able to
understand this line so let us ask chat
GPT to explain more
H
gbt so we have asked GPT what do you
mean by use for more complex UI
components that need to manage internal
state or respon on to life cycle events
so it says that managing internal state
is like class component have the ability
to have internal State and what does
State means State represents the data
that a component maintains and it can
change over the time for example in a
form component you might have an
internal state to track user input or a
counter component and it might have a
state to keep track of account so as you
can see all over here suppose here we
have class counter and it extends the
react component
here you have Constructor you have super
and here you have said this do state
equals to zero your count is zero then
you are incrementing your count by
saying this do state count and this do
state count plus one so basically here
you are increasing the state of the
count by one now you are rendering your
component by returning the count the
this state of count means here you are
returning the current state of the count
and on button onclick this increments to
one so basically this is in counter
button so on clicking plus it increases
the state of the count suppose if it has
zero if you click the state becomes one
similarly if you click again the state
of count becomes two so this is what
about managing internal States I hope so
you would have got brief idea regarding
this now respond to life cycle event
what are life cycle events react class
components have life cycle that consist
of different phases such as mounting
updating and unmounting so basically
it's telling about mounting updating and
unmounting which are life cycle of a
react now here you can see for example
it has given component did Mount or
component will Mount so what are these
things so let
us type all over
here
so guys as you can see all over here
while reading this if I'm getting doubt
anywhere I'm just reasing a Q&A type of
thing with the GPD so as you can see
it's a very effective way for learning
reactjs now let us see what is next now
we have completed water components in
react and finally comes to our last
topic that is understanding States in
react now let us ask GPT what are states
in
react
so guys I have asked GPT what are states
in react and GPT has given us this
answer in react the term State refers to
an object that represents the current
condition of a data of a component the
state of a component can change over
time when it does react rerenders that
component to reflect those changes in
the user interface it's very
understandable what it's trying to say
so now the second thing comes up how you
are going to declare your state state is
CED inside the component using use State
hook okay and Constructor method for
class component very simple guys suppose
here for counter I'm trying to put up
our state as a use state so for example
const count set count and here I have
set the state of count as zero now on
the paragraph I have shown the count and
on a button on click this counts state
has been increased to one so this is a
one fundamental example how you are
using the UST State hook and what are
basically States and similarly in the
class components how it's done so
basically your class is extending the
react component you have declared
Constructor which is receiving the props
then you are doing super for this props
and you have put the state for this
count as zero now on a paragraph you are
representing the state of the count
which is zero right now so on button on
click the state of this count is going
to get increased by one it is very
simple now the second comes up set State
now the set State function which is a
kind of a use State hook it is a kind of
an updat function for our functional
components and it is basically used to
update the state suppose in this piece
of code we have cons count set count
which is equals to use state zero and
here this do state where I'm putting
this do state count plus one so this is
a functional component using use State
okay now this is a class component which
is set up using the U state I hope so
you would have got a brief idea
regarding this so guys you can use chat
GPT for learning reactjs now it's very
amazing tool and you can ask any number
of question and it's not going to get
tired with that said guys that was all
for this video I hope so you would have
enjoyed our today's video on how to
learn react with Chad gbt staying ahead
in your career requires continuous
learning and upscaling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set your yourself on
the path to Career Success click the
link in the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here